Who wore a t-shirt saying Mossad? Tommy
Robinson. Who promotes IDF and Israel
and Zionism? Who says I'm a Zionist? Who
says when war happens I'll be the first
to go and fight? Tommy Robinson. And now
he is promoting Mossad. Mossad has
direct connections to Epson Islands.
Epson Islands was used to draw in bring
all these girls to uh get these powerful
men to blackmail them and film them.
Okay. So if anything, if anyone can be
labeled with pedophilia, pedophilia
apologist is who? Tommy Robinson.
pedophiles running to Israel for safe
haven.
>> Okay. Now, one second. Tommy Robinson.
Yes. This man who fits a profile of a a
a pedophile. Let's be honest with you.
Now, this man is telling us about
pedophilia, my friend. You
>> And you mean by that that many
pedophiles are like him. Not that
>> Yeah, of course. I'm not saying that.
Defamation.
>> Yeah. 100%. 100%. Yeah. But he might
send the letter to my kids house.
my two my my 2-year-old daughter baby
>> everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die that's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves brothers and
sisters masid Norway the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway subhan Allah where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray this masid It's only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count brothers and
sisters and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1,10,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makayyama are not. donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
>> This is this is a guy, right?
>> He's a fun.
>> We'll come to that. But this guy, Tommy
Robinson, let's just be honest. He's
he's attacking Islam all the time. When
was the last time you actually saw him
debate a Muslim?
>> No, he can't. He can't, bro.
>> But why? Why? If you want to be an
anti-Islamic apologist, why don't you
debate somebody?
>> If you watch video, bro, his face color
changed when he saw me.
>> They can't deal with it. But with them,
it's on a microphone, a video, etc. But
what I find very ironic is he accuses us
of being a pedophile apologist. But if
you look at look every accusation is a
is a confession because number one
firstly let's be look let's put in
perspective. If I go to Google now and
write
>> pedophile rings
>> most likely the men that I'm going to
see that are going to look like Tommy
Robinson from age from looks and it's
white middle-aged men. This guy is in
his mid-40s. He fits that profile
perfectly. Now
>> even the home office report says that as
well.
>> Who are we talking about? Who are you
talking about? Are you talking about
Tommy or
>> No. No. No, no, no. I'm talking about
I'm talking about Tommy Robinson. I'm
saying if you go and Google and write
pedophile rings, the men that you will
see there resemble Tommy Robinson.
>> They're white middle-aged men who are in
these acts. And not only that, we know
in his circles in the EDL, they were
pedophiles.
>> Absolutely.
>> Tell us that this
>> We'll get into it. Yeah. In a second.
But we wanted to watch a video.
>> Okay. So, this video
>> because because this PBD guy has been
speaking about me for too long now. Even
though he's too scared to speak to me.
Why are you scared then?
>> He's a cow. He's a coward. You never
know. There might be a possibility that
I'm not going to hurt you.
>> He might be on the list. He might be on
the list. He might be on the list.
>> I'm not going to hurt you.
>> He might be on the list, bro. You never
know because the way he's defending
Israel, he might on the list. The
Epstein list. Yeah.
>> You believe he's there. It might be.
>> Maybe they could possibly because the
way he's defending Israel. Now the thing
is now his co-host Adam who's an Israeli
is a is a Now check this out.
>> Listen to what he says. And he's talking
about Peter Fel apologist. Really,
>> bro. And check this out. You don't even
hear Patrick David speaking in this.
He's gone silent. Why?
>> Let's take a look at it. I want
accountability for everybody. If it's
Trump, if it's uh Bill Gates, if it's
Bill Clinton, I don't give a [__] If
it's the president of anything, expose
them because Adam, the truth has to come
out. Okay, good. He's consistent. Yeah.
He's saying, which is just whoever they
are, whatever they are, let them get
arrested. Correct. Guess what Adam has
to say. Let's see if he agrees or
disagrees.
>> Adam. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Let's see if he agrees.
>> Is he an official host of
>> Yes, bro. Official official. Official
co-host, bro. Look how Patrick Davis,
he's not even speaking. Watch what Adam
says. Check this out now. Yeah.
>> Silence.
>> Yeah. Watch this now. Watch this.
>> Okay. So, I only have one question for
you, my dear friend.
>> I agree with you,
>> but at what price?
>> Take a deep breath.
>> But hold me out. At what price? At to
what? Look, look, look, bro. Bro, there
there's pedophiles.
>> Bro, the guy was flying out girls.
>> Defending the perpetrators,
>> bro. He's defending the perpetrator and
he's saying
>> protecting them. In fact,
>> bro, just imagine if I said grooming
gangs. Yes,
>> we need to we need to expose them. I
agree. But at what cost? But what cost?
>> Bro, they will hang me upside down into
square. When the police were thinking at
what cost you're going to be, you know,
there's this community. The far right
were adamant. It doesn't matter what
cost, at any cost. We must protect our
children. However, over here, who are
you defending?
>> As Muslims, do we agree at any cost they
should be brought to justice? The
groomers, the people, all of them. But
Adam, Adam say no. Now listen carefully.
Watch this. Huh?
>> Any place animal.
>> So you're saying to expose whatever
happened on Epstein Island, you're
willing to do whatever this looks like?
Tear down the government, expose all the
secrets, put America basically in harm's
way just to find out what's help Adam.
>> Because these are the most powerful
people in the world, they're apparently
on this island.
>> Bro, he's basically saying because
they're the most powerful in the world,
>> they should be protected from uh
justice.
>> One sec. One second. And then and then
>> they should not be brought to justice.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. One second, bro.
Yeah.
>> And Patrick Pet Davis is calling us a
pedophile apologist.
>> And he's and this guy is the official
host,
>> bro. His co-host is saying
>> and he's silent about.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And he's talking. Yes. And
he goes maybe we should overlook it
because pedophiles. That's why they say
every accusation is a confession.
>> So you could say that he's you could
argue he's protecting the pedophiles
here,
>> bro. He's defending them, bro.
>> Defending the pedophiles.
>> It gets worse. Check this out,
>> Adam. So let the truth be told or the
heavens fall. I don't care. Yeah, Adam.
And that's who Vincent Oshana is. I am
100% accountability and I don't give if
Adam, if that's what we were built on.
>> What price? America. Guess what the
price is, Adam? God.
>> So, you want a price? You want to rule?
You're going to answer them.
>> You want to rule a city of ashes?
>> I don't give a [__] if it's built on
pedophilia and raping kids. Yes. Because
you're being emotional,
>> bro. Imagine if I said to you or someone
and I go, "You're just being emotional,
man. Let's look at the bigger picture.
groom and gang here. They did this to
girls, but let's look at the bigger
picture. How it's going to affect Islam.
Let's let's turn a blend a blind eye.
Let's not talk about it, bro. Do you
know what that means? And you are.
>> You're just being emotional.
>> Thank you. Imagine. Good. If I said
that, imagine he said that, bro. They
would massacre us. Okay. No, I'm being
real.
>> You have to understand the whole concept
of do you want to cut your nose off to
spite your face? There might be an
issue, but do you want to cut your whole
nose off and ruin your entire face
because you care that much about this
entire
>> He's basically belittling, bro. There
are pedophiles in America. There's a
documentary about the return the return
to uh
>> for geopolitical not Israel. What's it
called? The return of the right.
>> There are pedophiles running to Israel
for safe haven.
>> Okay. Now, one second. Tommy Robinson.
Yes. This man who fits a profile of a a
a pedophile. Let's be honest with you.
Now, this man is telling us about
pedophilia. My friend.
>> And you mean by that that many
pedophiles are like him. Not that he's
>> Yeah, of course. I'm not saying that
defamation.
>> Yeah. 100% 100% but he might send the
letter to my kids house.
My two my 2-year-old daughter baby.
Okay. So, he's that same guy who's
wearing a Mosad shirt.
>> What?
>> What a contemptable junk.
>> No, no, no. Let's see. No, hold on a
second.
>> What a contemptable junk he is.
>> Now, Dishan, you know very well the
connection between Epstein,
>> his his rise to power, unqualified. Like
they say, it's not what you know, it's
who you know.
>> Okay? Who he was working with. and he
worked his way up to a multi-billion
pound corporation of investment. Yes.
>> And who are these people, bro? Summary.
Okay. It's my little not staff. Yeah.
Okay. Um Epstein was he went to
university. He was not a gradu. He had
no graduation. No um qualifications.
Okay.
>> Reminds me of both of these men here.
>> Yeah. Not only that me definitely. Yeah.
The only thing is I didn't have an
island, a pedophile island. Okay. Okay.
He then got hired by Alan Cber and he
became a partner in six years time to a
corporation of multi-billion pounds.
Okay. He was not um even though um Alan
C. Granberg was not an Israeli, he was
an American businessman born in Wikita,
Kansas and raised in Oklahoma City. He
was prominent figure in American
finances and most notably the former CEO
and chairman of Bur Sterns and was also
a major philanthropist.
>> Philanthropist.
>> Philanthropist. Thank you guys for a
Jewish cause Jewish cause uh cause at
home in Israel. Okay. Now Jeff Jeffrey
Epson and Cole and um he started working
with someone called Les Wexner. Yeah.
Was the he was the only one who only
worked with Epson openly. Okay. And he
was someone that owned Victoria Secrets.
So Victoria Secrets you have these
models who come in and obviously you
know
>> Victoria Secret you know the underwear
and all that kind of stuff.
>> Yeah about no.
>> Yeah. So so
basically what they say is that he would
use that um area. No, no, no. He would
use that to groom the girls.
>> So these girls that will come to be
modeling, etc., he would take them to
the islands. Yes. Exactly. Now, Robert
Maxwell, Robert Maxwell was a Mosset
agent allegedly. And his daughter,
Gizlane Maxwell. Okay. Robert Maxwell
was a prominent uh was most prominent
company was a Maxwell Communication
Corporation, MCC, which which evolved
from his acquisition of the British
Printing Corporation. He he owned a few
companies. He owned the Daily Mirror. We
know the Daily Mirror newspaper. Yeah.
And he was involved
>> Victoria Secret.
>> No, it was Lex Wex.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Okay. And he was
involved in establishing Maxwell
Foundation after his death at the MCC
was sold is not known. No, you can cut
this. Okay. Now, check this out. When he
died, a mysterious death by the way.
Some say he had hearts and fell in the
water. And
>> they say they say suicide.
>> Okay. Yeah. He was buried in the
mountain of olives in Jerusalem which
was attended by six former Israeli Mosad
agents. And then Israeli Prime Minister
Sham said he's done more for Israel than
he can than can be told. Okay. His
daughter worked closely with who?
Epstein. Okay. Now, Ren Alexander Aosta
is an American attorney and politician.
He said Epstein belongs to the
intelligence. Leave him alone. Now,
there's more connections to be made. The
point is what? Who wore a t-shirt saying
Mossad? Tommy Robinson. Who promotes IDF
and Israel and Zionism? Who says I'm a
Zionist? Who says when the war happens,
I'll be the first to go and fight? Tommy
Robinson. And now he is promoting
Mossad. Mossad has direct connections to
Epson Islands. Epson Islands was used to
draw in bring all these girls to uh get
these powerful men to blackmail them and
film them. Okay. So if anything if
anyone can be labeled with pedophilia or
pedophilia apologist is who? Tommy
Robinson. And not only that, Patrick Pet
David his co-host Adam is belittling and
undermining and saying turn a blind eye
to the pedophilia and the girls being
raped. So the point I'm seeing is this.
You're accusing us of something that
like I said, every accusation is a
confession. So to me, it's ironic that
they are dare to call us pedophile
apologists when this pedophile issue is
a white man's issue. With all due
respect, yes, it's not our problem.
Mossad's connection to the island.